chers amis bonjour et bienvenue dans ce
cinquième numéro de friends live alors
si vous découvrez les missions fremm
style c'est une émission qui a lieu deux
fois par semaine les mardis et vendredis
à 17 heures et au cours de ces deux
secteurs bien sympathique je reçois deux
vidéastes avec qui on va discuter
librement de leur travail on va pas la
situation actuelle on va parler de leurs
suggestions culturel est avec moi à la
régie sellami vince que vous ne pouvez
pas entendre qu'elle accomplit son micro
mais il appréciera les commentaires
sympathiques sur le tchad n'en doutez
pas virginie est là pour prendre vos
questions sur le chat d'ailleurs donc
n'hésitez pas à poser donc pour nos deux
invités les questions qui seront
transmises et gelé poserez à mon tour
cette émission est réalisable le soutien
du cnc
merci à eux et pour commencer cette
émission je vais accueillir ma première
invitée qui est une quête une géologue
c'est valentine de la chaîne sciences de
comptoir bonjour valentine à lui patrick
bonjour à tous alors valentine
il est de coutume dans cette émission de
ceux de se présenter pour ceux qui
n'auraient pas la chance de te connaître
donc est ce que tu peux nous parler un
petit peu de ton parcours et de ce qui
t'a conduit à créer sa chaîne youtube ok
alors version courte
je suis journée de scientifiques avec un
background de géologie et de biologie et
j'ai la chaîne youtube sciences de
comptoir qui parle de cailloux après la
version de je peux dire que j'ai une
licence en géologie
après j'ai des sur 40 biologique quand
je suis revenu un peu à la raison que
j'ai fait un master en biologie
évolutive
puis j'ai fait après une année de césure
g faire un master en journalisme
scientifique à paris diderot
suite à quoi on parle aussi de quoi j'ai
travaillé pendant deux ans pour sciences
et avenir en tant que vidéaste est là
depuis un mois je suis youtube aux
professionnels pour ma chienne d'accord
alors moi pour te dire comment j'ai
découverte la chaîne donc c'était il ya
un an et demi à peu près c'était sur le
tournage de la deuxième saison du vortex
et donc c'était ma nombril qui m'a parlé
de la chaîne et qui m'a dit oui
valentine ont qu'elle parle de cailloux
et de hockey sur le papier ça va pas
plaire forcément très très sexy et puis
j'ai regardé une vidéo est là j'étais
absolument subjugué par le talent avec
lequel tu réussis à vendre le truc
intéressant et surtout drôle alors qu'à
priori c'est pas forcément gagner pour
rendre ce sujet la comique et tu as une
des chaînes sans doute les plus
marrantes qu'ils soient alors que c'est
une chaîne de vulgarisation à la base
et voilà bravo pour sa bravoure pour
avoir réussi à rendre ce sujet vraiment
marrant est intéressant est la première
vidéo que j'ai vu que j'avais vu tu
expliquait d'ailleurs gelé découvert au
passage tu expliquer pourquoi les
géologues lèche les cailloux oui alors
pour les gens qui me qui ne comprennent
pas de quoi je suis en train de parler
est ce que tu pourrais nous expliquez
nous résumer du coup pourquoi est ce que
les géologues lèche des cailloux alors
il hd cadiot a pour avoir leurs fins et
distingué premièrement pour se sentir
exister en tant que soit donc pour en
fait parce que les chats et les chiens
cailloux cela permet d'avoir plein
d'informations sûres sur l'échantillon
en question quand on essaie de
l'identifier donc par exemple s'il a un
goût salé ça peut être battu c'est
logiquement donc le ciel de taxes qu'on
appelle de lâayoune sahara minérale
sinon ça peut être d'autres types de
trucs marrants gros ça permet vraiment
de resserrer le faisceau de
l'identification autour de quelques
spécimens
si l'on ne peut aussi évoluer évaluer sa
porosité donc s'y colle à la langue
c'est qu'il est pour eux c'est ça marche
pour des argiles ça marche pour les
poteries aussi en archéologie
c'est c'est le club assez sauvage qui
m'a dit qu'il est ça aussi
archéologie exergue lors qu'il est chaud
des poteries
oui tu peux aller chez des peausseries
la gtd aussi des fossiles gens plein de
trucs genre des jeux 10
je ne sais pas si ça se fait mais en
théorie ce que vous portez dans le lot
la structure interne des os en fait
c'est plein d'albums et comme il ya de
l'air à l'intérieur ça va aspirer ta
langue tu lé dessus
voilà encore plein de choses très
simples à skis mais on peut faire
d'autres trucs que les chais des
cailloux on peut aussi les reggae pour
aider à les identifier donc si on
n'arrive à rien un caillou avec son
ongle à ce moment là ça peut être que de
rares truc par exemple un petit peu ça
peut être de la calcite et surtout ça
peut être du talent qui sait le talk
sous forme de cailloux ce qu'on appelle
la stéatite et c'est extrêmement tendres
donc à vraiment tu peux tu peux le rayer
à l'ongle tu t'enfonces dedans comme
dans du beurre espérer que cette formule
là par rapport à ça par rapport à la
dureté et la tendreté de la pierre il ya
une autre vidéo
d'ailleurs dans laquelle tu dévoiles le
moyen mnémotechnique quand les géologues
c'est ça pour classer la dureté des
pierres on est d'accord
la bêtise et des ce que tu veux est ce
que tu peux nous donner ce moyen de mots
technique est donc réel
oui assez tagro ce concierge folle
d'amour aux quémander tes caresses dit
l'ennemi ce qu'en fait c'est une échec
initial c'est génial enfin non je veux
dire au cnt
si tu prends chaque initiales de chaque
mot ça donne un minéral sur l'échelle de
référence de dureté des minéraux qui
s'appelle l'échelle de moss ou encore
saas et talk par exemple le gros c'est
le gypse j'ai dit une bêtise alors on
fait le gypse doit pouvoir travailler à
londres ont aussi rassuré petit bétail
dans ta vidéo qui ce qui s'appelle
d'ailleurs non tu l'as tu l'as tu lui a
pas donné le nom de la méthode de noter
dixie d'accrocher la grosse concierge
folle d'amour donc le titre est
surréaliste quand on voit mais non c'est
très très sérieux et donc dans ta vidéo
tu me
8pour évidemment que qu'on abandonne
cette formule un petit peu seul est et
qu'on trouve quelque chose d'un petit
peu moins problématique est ce que et sk
une part de sérieux dans cette histoire
où est-ce que c'est ta maman pour ce
propos rire quand il s'agit de son reer
et parce que j'aime bien le concept de
lancer des pétitions en ligne parce que
je sais pas on a l'impression de sauver
le monde quand on a signé une pétition
lui et du coup je me suis dit que là
c'était l'occasion pertinents mais moi
ce qui me révolte qui dans ce moyen
mnémotechnique c'est qu'ils nous tuent
toi tu auras pas
tagro ce concierge effective je suis un
petit peu choqué mais là je pense qu'en
quelques minutes les gens qui nous
regardent et qui ne connaissait pas ta
chaîne on appris de trucs tellement
incroyable que les géologues l'âge des
cailloux et on s'est tu sais cette
technique long pour se souvenir de la
dureté des pierres moi personnellement
c'est un choc
et on apprend beaucoup de choses comme
ça sur pattes chalet un autre truc qui
est vraiment surprenant pour une chaîne
de vulgarisation scientifique c'est que
il ya énormément d'humour absurde sur la
chaîne et on est vraiment on est
vraiment dans un esprit à la monty
python on en reparlera un peu plus tard
quand on évoquera t suggestions
culturelle met donc on sent vraiment que
cette inspiration cette influence que
quelle quelle importance a pour toi est
ce que dell des comptes a lancé la
chaîne dans l'idée de mettre à peu près
autant d'humour que de sciences ou c'est
venu plus en le faisant alors non ce
n'était pas du tout le plan à la bad
à la base j'ai essayé plein de trucs
différents c'était surtout des projets
de masters que je mettais en ligne sur
la chaîne ça me faisait des petits
exercices des trucs comme ça mais
c'était très sérieux très guindé et où
je me suis dit ça me faire un book de
journalistes et puis une fois j'ai des
amis qui m'ont dit mais pourquoi t'es
chiant comme ça dans ta vidéo ou alors
que j'ai pas dans la vraie vie et du
coup là je me suis dit bon je peux
peut-être essayer de faire une vidéo un
peu rigolote pour voir qui me
ressemblerait et c'est comme ça qui est
arrivé la première vidéo de cailloux et
comme ça a bien marché que moi je me
suis vraiment amusé pour la première
fois sur une vidéo je ne suis pas je
vais continuer parce que c'est ce qui me
plaît puisque est-ce que tu là
sans ticket en termes d'impact tout de
suite est ce que tu as vu que cette
vidéo la dirai plus de monde que
d'habitude
ah bah oui complètement j'ai eu des très
bons retours et des retours très
positifs et j'ai remarqué un truc c'est
que j'apprécie plus à un commentaire qui
me dit j'ai bien rigolé comme en attaque
il dit j'ai bien appris c'est
complètement l'idée parce que c'est
peut-être plus dur à mon avis c'est même
beaucoup plus dur de réussir à faire
marrer les gens que le rapport d'un truc
donc c'est à laymont compétentes ça
dépend donc on apprend mais est il ya un
personnage qui est devenue culte dans
cette vidéo c'est ta soeur jumelle
décédé jonathan est là elle aime vie
absolument pas de pétoncles à elle
pouvait pas dire parce qu'elle est en
train de s'arrêter est né à elle s'est
lui aussi fait aux mines c'est en fait
mes vidéos sont co présentée et surtout
une des vidéos qui est un profond son
émission de télé nul était co présentée
par matthieu jumelles morte
voilà où on donne la réplique comme ça
donc là j'espère que les gens qui ne
connaissent pas taschen vont se
précipiter dessus parce que ça fait
beaucoup d'informations assez étrange
assimilés donc vous n'êtes pas plus sur
cette histoire de seurre allez voir par
vous même donc tu nous expliquer que tu
étais journaliste scientifique au débat
et que tu ne devais plus actuellement
donc tu as quittés sur cette bien c'est
ça oui âge
alors je travaille pour avant j'étais à
plein temps pour eux et maintenant je
vais continuer mes plus en pige donc je
continue d'être journaliste scientifique
pour eux et d'autres médias en pige
mais en fait ce qui était mon hobby est
devenu mon activité principale et ce qui
était mon activité principale est devenu
moins bien pas de géant vers tvb
d'accord et la non par exemple est-ce
que tu as de nouveaux projets pour la
chaîne ou est-ce que la situation
actuelle forcément fait que c'est
compliqué tout le monde un petit peu
comment ça se passe qu'elle est de
l'avenir de la chaîne pour toi bats
l'avenir est plutôt radieux
ouais oui parce que j'ai décroché
l'indicé en fait donc je vais pouvoir
sur avis et puis alors à la base il ya
une vidéo je vais sortir demain si tout
se passe bien c'est l'âge où elle a
filmé à en extérieur et tout mais
évidemment ce sera pas possible
mais je me suis reviennent à un petit
studio à l'intérieur et puis je tourne
en intérieur et jeu le film et je
montais points au final ça change pas
grand chose sur mon workflow que cette
chance d'éjecter la d'accord et est-ce
que indépendamment de tâches et
personnel j'ai d'autres projets
collectifs
alors j'ai d'autres projets oui j'aime
moi tu veux en venir
[Rires]
alors j'ai participé à une pierre une
vidéo sur rétro nous vous en avait parlé
dans le premier live avec par mois le
live avec les abbés l'eau avec nota bene
pardon du coup le feu voilà donc là je
sais en partenariat avec la bnf en fait
c'est le fonds documentaire de
d'articles de presse de la bnf donc là
ça va sortir normalement bientôt et je
participe aussi à la prochaine saison du
vortex
donc voilà avec montée de linguistique
est avec angle droit et avec un créatif
et que ça promet de tout chez ma tante a
ainsi qu'un peu originale cette fois
avec un peu plus de jeu que d'habitude
vous avez déjà tourné là vous avez en
février alors donc pour ceux qui ne
connaissent pas le vortex aller voir la
chaîne du vortex sur youtube
donc il y avait en ligne est donc là
vous avez tourné la troisième et dont je
rappelle que c'est une colocation de
vidéastes 4 vidéaste à chaque fois et
donc chaque vidéaste fait trois vidéos
donc j'en avais fait douze au total
et ça a duré dix douze jours vous aussi
c'est à peu près sain le tournage oui
c'était une dizaine de gens que je crois
et celle des épisodes qui font entre 15
et 20 minutes
ah ouais donc c'est plus long que la
saison
peur dans les épisodes en prime alors
j'ai cru comprendre qu'il y avait plus
de fictions sur cette saison là mais
est-ce que cela sans trop en dévoiler
ouais bah on a toute une intrigue et
alors les épisodes peuvent toujours se
regardent et indépendamment mais si on
les regarde dans l'ordre tout ça raconte
une histoire très bien alors on avait
une question j'ai l'impression que c'est
un petit peu du troll un tu nous diras
question de dounia salese tu vas connaît
d'accord auquel nous dit à quoi bon
escient que penses tu des sciences
sociales
alors je pense que la géologie leur est
supérieur de toute façon et raison de la
question mais qu'est ce que je pense de
la psychologie évolutionniste et enfin
révolutionnaire et je pense aussi que la
géologie des supérieurs de toute façon
d'accord alors moi je me sers tous à
deux regards extérieurs évidemment mais
j'ai l'impression qu'à une petite
guéguerre comme ça des disciplines
notamment avec 7,9 de bonne foi lui il à
la chaîne au mot fabulous et c'est lui
qui fait la psychologie évolutionnaire
ne sais pas voilà donc ça les sciences
cognitives quoi est ok et voilà il ne
crache sur la géologie temps qui peut et
on aime pour ça évidemment je réponds
que vous pouvez poser toutes vos
questions dans le tchad posez vos
questions à valentine n'hésitez pas en
chine en tant qu' en tant que
scientifique
en tant que journaliste scientifique
bulgarie that he is est ce que c'est un
point de vue particulier sur la
situation actuelle ou pas du tout est ce
que tu t'en des tâches plus tôt il y en
a qui préfère ne pas y penser ne pas y
réfléchir ce que toi ta spécialité fait
que tu as un regard particulier sur ce
qui se passe alors ma spécialité
voudrait que je me tienne au courant de
ce qui se fait mais comme je viens de
quitter le plus
constant d'informations en temps la
rédaction j'essaye un peu de me tenir à
l'écart de tout ça donc je sais que les
informations les plus importantes ne
parviendront de toute façon par le
filtre des réseaux sociaux et des
discussions entre amis donc j'essaye de
me tenir un peu à l'écart de tout ça
parce que j'ai commencé à sentir le
moment où ça devenait trop anxiogène
pour moi au début je me tenais très au
courant et puis au fur à mesure je me
suis dit là j'arrive à un seuil où je la
prendrai pas plus d'informations que ça
donc j'ai essayé de décrocher un peu et
voilà donc je peux pas vous donner des
informations fraîches sur la question
d'accord pas une question dans le chat
d'une personne cinéphiles manifestement
gorge profonde qui nous dit comment as
tu été amenés à faire journaliste
scientifique comment tout a commencé
j'étais au lycée en fait
et au moment de vous savez le dur moment
de l'orientation on doit choisir quel
métier on va faire pendant les soixante
années et j'ai pas être gelée fouillé
absolument toutes les fiches de l'onisep
et tout est d'ailleurs je remercie
beaucoup ma mère et mon frère qui
beaucoup [ __ ] aussi pour ta et je
cherchais un bété qui soit à la fois
littéraire et scientifique et qu'on m'a
proposé ingénieur poète et on m'a
proposé journaliste scientifique je me
suis dit le deuxième cela puisse journal
parce que j'aimais bien écrire raconter
des histoires tout comme ça et puis ce
qui est bien c'est qu'en plus il ya
plein de médium plein de médias
différents qu'on peut utiliser aussi
bien les cris on peut écrire des bd on
peut écrire des articles des livres
faire des vidéos des documentaires
tellement de trucs à faire via ce métier
j'ai vraiment vide alors valentine sais
tu ce que fait david lynch pendant le
confinement
non il vient pendant le confinement
david lynch fabrique des petites lampes
voilà c'est très lynch est donc ça veut
mais ma question suivante est-ce que
donc toi même tu occupes ce temps de
confinement en fabricant des petites
landes d'autres objets ou est-ce que
voilà tu tu occupes ton temps d'une
manière différente de l'habitude est ce
que tu fais des choses que tu n'avais
pas le temps de faire avant comment tu
occupes ce temps alors je ne fais pas
des petites lampes mais je fais des
petites guitares
[Rires]
bah oui c'est moi avec du papier et du
scotch et de la colle et je pourrai 6
baies de petite étagère
[Rires]
on a l'impression que c'est à peu près à
l'histoire des petites landes
mais je ne savais pas quel effet ça
incroyable écoute voilà j'ai fait des
petites lettres aussi avec elle diffère
par dedans
est-ce que tu prévois vraiment de faire
carrément a pris ma came derrière de
maison avec tout le mobilier ou c'est
ponctuel
alors c'était ponctuel en fait au départ
je me suis dit je vais me faire une
corona maison en 3d ce sera un peu ma
maison du confinement et puis j'ai eu la
flemme au bout d'un moment et du coup
j'ai juste fait une étagère une guitare
avec des antilles d'yves rossy olemps
croyable et commentée du carton c'est
qu'est-ce que service et du carton en
fait je m'étais intéressé aux meubles en
carton il ya quelques années quand
j'étais pauvre et du coup que je vais
vraiment blanc carton et et là du coup
j'ai repris le même mécanisme j'avais
posté des photos sur twitter et quelques
semaines en fait s'il faut faire une
structure il faut découper le carton
dans le bon sens des canaux et une telle
structure en 3d avec différents plans
comme ça et puis après j'ai tout
recouvert avec du papier d'un goût
douteux
non mais il est agirs harbinger vidéo de
google d'ailleurs j'ai l'impression
d'être et d'agir c'est une chose mais je
vois que tu as fait aussi un petit remix
cube l'intérieur oui j'ai tenté il
importe les craintes du carton aussi oui
non c'est du papier ça j'ai fait un
petit bug dont je vais essayer de sortir
moi c'est vraiment impressionnant
qu'est ce qu'il ya dans le magasin truc
là non alors il y avait un bouquet de
fleurs de thym qui est complètement ch
et depuis nous c'est que je suis
vraiment impressionné de cette liste un
je serai encore beaucoup plus loin que
lynch
les professionnels et ben bravo bravo
c'est vraiment très fort alors naître de
nouvelles questions qui sont arrivés les
jeunes disposent les rebelles de l'est à
belo tient d'ailleurs une collègue diane
qui nous dit tu vas faire quoi sur la
chaîne nouvelle série nouveau format
point d'interrogation à a alors l'idée
c'est de partir repose sur la même chose
donc des caillots et du rire et et c'est
un des formats plus longs au moins 10
minutes
là j'ai une vidéo qui devrait sortir
demain je leur dis parce que c'est
suffisamment important pour moi qui fais
une quinzaine de minutes
donc c'est des formats un peu plus long
avec des contenus un peu plus fouillé
donc on verra ce que ça donne mais sinon
ce sera la même chose avec des sujets un
peu l'idée c'est de tracer des ponts
entre la géologie et d'autres
disciplines donc là la vidéo demain ce
sera le lien entre géologie essence de
l'environnement après j'en ai une
logique philosophie sera pas tout de
suite mais validé c'est vraiment d'aller
un peu impôts plus lourds d'accord et
moi j'ai une autre question est ce que
tu aurais envie d'aller davantage vers
vers l'humour et à la fiction en
laissant de côté l'aspect pédagogique
bas est-ce que c'est donc elle plante
pas du tout balade à moins évidemment
que j'ai fait sur la chaîne parle
techniquement c'est plus était fan de
boxe donc on m'a cité plus tôt qu'il a
fait je suis juste personnage principal
c'est franchement juste de la fiction
pour le coup et franchement c'était bien
rigolo à faire donc c'est en fait une à
une pause pub pour un microscope pour
femme qui s'appelle le microscope
d'accord très bien donc ça ça va venir
vidéo en date contre la surtaxe
ok donc savourer le takara d'autres
projets comme ça plus tard très bien il
est temps de nous parler de tes
recommandations culturel pour nos amis
qui s'ennuient en confinement et c'est
bien gentil de ta part de leur donner
des conseils
alors que vas-tu nous proposer lundi
alors j'ai trois séries à vous proposer
elles sont pas toutes récentes mais je
les aime beaucoup beaucoup c'est des
séries anglaises d'humour évidemment
parce que sinon c'est pas drôle
donc il ya delighted 30 bien évidemment
référence absolue gm a besoin de me
l'avoir fait connaître celle là elle est
incroyable et d'une fois en fait ça
raconte l'histoire de sa le quotidien du
service informatique d'une grande
entreprise
on sait toujours pas ce que fait cette
entreprise d'ailleurs dans mon talent et
il leur arrive plein de trucs
complètement rocambolesque qui est
vraiment drôle et il me semble que la
série s'est arrêtée à la saison 4 pour
le moment voilà seize ans trois jeunes
se fassent ça s'est arrêté
en plein en plein succès quoi et ça fait
des années qu'on attend la nouvelle
saison qui m'arrivera sans doute jamais
malheureusement parce que ça fait quand
même longtemps là qu'ils ont arrêté mais
c'est clair que c'est un petit bijou
d'humour pour ceux qui ne connaissent
pas et y croire c'est barclays les blés
plus les plus drôles entre moi ça ne
devait préférer en tout cas et c'est les
personnages surtout et notamment moss
oui voilà donc pour ceux qui connaissent
la série donc must c'est une espèce de
nerd qui est un petit peu handicapé au
niveau des relations sociales on va dire
et qui est donc interprété par richard
ayoade qui est un comédien exceptionnel
et donc quand tu quand tu m'as dit que
deux côtés mais cette série j'ai tout de
suite pensé à une petite histoire qui
m'est arrivé car figure toi que alors
que j'étais dans un snack à avignon
pendant le festival d'avignon il ya deux
ans de ça non et j'étais seule avec ma
compagne dans le snack et là je me
retourne et je vois moss désir que c'est
fou c'est improbable être pompier est
mort et sa femme et leurs enfants
et là je vraiment c'est pas du tout mon
genre de faire ça je me dis c'est pas
possible je peux pas ne pas aller vers
lui c'est trop improbable et donc je
suis allé les voir je dis que j'adorais
la serre etc et il était extrêmement
sympathique donc voilà cette rencontre
un problème avec avec mos qui est dans
la vraie vie bien sûr au cou - quoi
maladroit beaucoup moins gauche que la
série série charmed il est aussi il est
aussi réalisateur et auteur
donc voilà la série est géniale et
voulais vous parler d'autres séries
anglaises qui sont un peu dans le même
esprit oui mais je n'en reviens pas de
cette anecdote un je t'admire encore
plus malheureusement j'ai pas de photos
parce qu'il n'a pas voulu en prendre
j'ai pas vraiment dire que j'ai demandé
si on pouvait faire une photo un sage et
bon voila tu veux indiquer quand même de
quoi j'ai juste dit que j'aimais
beaucoup ce qu'il faisait mais je vais
pas vous lombardie l'été en famille ça
mais mais voilà heureusement que j'ai
témoin cas donc mac mais qui a bien vu
quelques pommes moss était là mais même
s'ils ne le connaissaient pas donc elle
n'a pas bien compris pourquoi j'étais
comme un fou mais voilà donc je t'en
prie parle-nous de la deuxième série oui
la deuxième série s'appelle father ted
je crois qu'elle est du même auteur je
suis pas sûr g la unam trek très
compétent j'aime bien tout cas c'est
sans doute plus ou moins la même équipe
et je me retrouve dans ses selles même
type d'humour et là pour le coup ça
raconte l'histoire de trois personnes
encore mais pas du tout les mêmes
ces trois prêtres qui sont tellement
mauvais ou qu'on fait des choses
tellement horrible dans leur vie que ils
ont été relégués sur une pauvre île
perdue en irlande où il ya même pas de
route faille à rien du tout et il arrive
des trucs complètement horrible à chaque
fois et c'est très très irrévérencieux
ça attaque absolument tout la religion
le féminisme le gracie enfin tout est et
c'est vraiment très drôle de mes
lectrices
oui comme très souvent dans les séries
anglaises en général ça va beaucoup plus
loin que les séries us quand on voit par
exemple les versions britanniques et
américaines dix offices en général c'est
beaucoup plus trash et beaucoup plus
politiquement incorrect dans la version
britannique très peu de limites quand
donc ok prasert r j'ai donc la troisième
oui la troisième à c'est aussi une
terrible est drôle parce que je suis un
peu monomaniaque s'appelle l'ipl britten
là pour le coup elle est incroyable et
parle des autres ci est en fait là c'est
une série de sketches qui fait très
monty python est assez les deux mêmes
acteurs qui se grime en plein de
personnages différents chaque fois et
qui jouent des scènes différentes et est
resté à mourir de rire et pendant
faux-pas survendre s'est passablement
drôle et même la voie aux clés est
hilarante
donc c'est marc entre le camp magna
plein de gags il y en a certains que
j'ai piqué d'ailleurs que j'ai auquel
j'ai rendu hommage dans mes vidéos alors
celle là je la connais pas pour le coup
mais est ce que toi tu connais red dwarf
ou pas ah non tu connais par edouard
comlan pense que tu vas tu vas apprécié
parce qu'on est vraiment dans le même
délire
sauf que là c'est de la science fiction
en fait très noir pour le résumer très
grossièrement red door c'est un peu
comme s'il star trek rencontré dire et
icloud et c'est une série culte qui a eu
pas mal pas mal de saisons qui s'est
arrêté quelques années également mais je
pense que ça va ça va beaucoup de perles
et si vous n'êtes pas des douars et que
vous aimez l'humour anglais et la sfc
incontournable donc
donc voilà valentine est ce que tu es ce
que tu conseilles de lécher ci ont donc
si on est confiné en appartements dont
nous demandent les vélos amis à tu peux
tu peux a lâché plein de choses tu peux
aller chez tes murs son style pas de la
peinture au plomb chez toi ça c'est des
colliers ou de l'amiante c'est des coups
de pub lente
évidemment ce n'est pas une bonne idée
pour la petite anecdote aussi j'avais
j'avais ramené un caillou chez moi que
je trouvais absolument magnifique
il est incroyable il était blanc vert
avec qui et filandreux est tous vraiment
venu d'ailleurs et puis je me suis
renseigné dessus et j'ai vu que c'était
de l'amiante et du coup je les ai jetés
très vite mais il ya une question un jeu
qui me dira si tu comprends la question
gay sur le dry dry qui nous dit c'est
quoi la pire pépites de science de
comptoir que t'ai entendu au bar ou
peut-être avec comptoir tu comprends la
question oui jalel la pire la piraterie
en masse aux scientifiques que j'aurais
pu en entendre au comptoir d'un bar
protocole d'accord d'accord exactement
là je comprends alors il ya une fois où
c'était quand même assez extraordinaire
c'était dans le sud c'était tellement
complètement absurde que j'ai
enregistrée à conversation je me suis
dit après je pourrais être en fin
d'épisode en débarquant au fur et à
mesure et finalement je n'ai pas fait
parce que je vois là mais il y avait une
grande discussion sur les lobbys
pharmaceutiques les vaccins être comme
ça c'est ça marche et c'est fort c'est
un trajet pas d'anecdotes en particulier
quoi c'était plus tout à un discours
falaise d'hallendre les deux heures
d'accord mais est ce que est ce que tu
apprécies toutes les théories du complot
diverses et variées qu'on a vu
qu'on a vu émerger dans le sillon du
corps d'un virus il y en a toutes les
semaines il y avait de nouveau qui
émergent aux jeunes mères mais arabe a
dit j'ai mangé ma théorie du complot
c'est que je sais pas si tu as vu
réponse j'en avais déjà pas dans ce live
donc réponse elle est confinée dans sa
tour d'accord qu'elle tard et c'est
vraiment fou quand même déjà comme une
confidence et donc la théorie ce serait
que disney de récré ce virus pour que
les gens s'abonnent en masse à disney +
cependant le confinement
aujourd'hui assez satisfait de ma
théorie du complot
je trouve que ça se tient pas mal on a
une très belle coïncidence donc je vais
je la donne a qui veulent à relayer ça
me fait plaisir c'est cadeau tallandier
ce plus un plaisir de t'avoir en notre
compagnie c'était cette émission je
rappelle que donc on peut retrouver
toutes les vidéos sur ta chaine sciences
de comptoir et il y en a combien
rattraper pour l'instant à peu près des
vidéos drôles
il doit en avoir quatre ou cinq je pense
que c'est une demain à du corps mais
drôle ça veut dire que tu comptes pas
toutes les vidéos alors ah oui avant
c'était avancer les vidéos chiante part
relative émission les pages région ok
bon alors on invite les gens à aller
voir toutes les vidéos que c'est
re bonjour les amis désolé pour chaque
petit bug technique les aléas du direct
comme le veut la formule consacrée
on est de retour avec on parler de ton
parcours thibault donc tu nous expliquer
que voilà au départ tu étais professeur
depuis lohse de philosophie
effectivement j'étais essor du film de
filles j'ai commencé par faire un
doctorat dans ça et donc j'ai enseigné
pendant que je terminais mon doctorat et
ensuite quand j'ai fini je me suis senti
un peu vide un parent à la suite de
celle de ce gros morceau
j'ai eu l'idée de le lancer de car ce
que j'avais en tête depuis un moment
parce que j'aimais beaucoup la
virtualisation et je trouvais qu'il
n'avait pas attendu chose en philo je
regardais plus de la figuration
scientifiques de toute façon mais jean
prat choses étaient loin pour regarder
ce qui se défient l'australie avait
essentiellement cyrus north et a reçu le
livret l'émission et mais du coup
c'était de lattes
c'était un niveau assez lycéens c'est
l'émotion
- evènements que lycéen à quelques pas
en tout cas la taille n'est pas vraiment
ce qu'on pouvait on peut faire en
philosophie et qui est personnel
personnellement quand je parle de tâche
n est que experts de la chaîne de cyrus
ce que je dis et que cyrus il est là
vraiment pour initier les gens qui n'ont
pas de notion en philosophie au concept
classique aux grands auteurs
c'est vraiment une porte d'entrée et toi
tu es là pour les prendre au niveau
d'après en fait on pour lé concept un
peu plus pointu donc je trouve que vous
un complément termes exactement ça très
clairement on n'est pas du tout sur la
même sur donner à notre rubrique
quelques bars de pression et nana
attentes et met donc du coup 2010 et moi
il ya moyen de faire quelque chose de
fort et marché avec l'excellente le truc
qui m'a vraiment donné envie c'était de
voir des virades à tort comme michaël
youn est en fait parce que c'était
deluga régulateur quittez pas qu'ils
aient pas informés des trucs
relativement simple et je me disais je
peux m'imaginer faire ça quand je
regardais les cloches de regarder les
eaux grasses et
grasset comme aller au guardian ne peut
pas faire ça mais ne pas être aussi cool
que les eaux grasses et c'est pas
possible c'est pas humain puis
performant et par contre quand je
regardais milk and honey c'était je veux
plus me dire ah ben tiens effectivement
tacler le mystère tu peux tu parles de
ces témoins au niveau du contenu aussi
parce que ça va ça présenter des trucs
relativement qui pouvait passer enfin
j'apprenais des trucs quoi et donc je me
suis dit je vais essayer de faire un
truc dans ce goût là mais pour la philo
et j'ai commencé ça j'ai fait ça en même
temps j'ai enseigné pendant qu'on rend
donc une avance à marcher bien j'ai
décidé d'arrêter je ne signe à plein
temps là dessus ce qui était un peu
risqué bien le dire mais finalement je
suis bien content d'avoir général et
donc quand tu as dans cette tâche n
c'était c'était avec telle vidéo tu as
commencé comment j'ai commencé avec une
idée qui s'appelait en trucs à
l'économiste intellectuelle dans la
philosophie est elle de l'onanisme
d'intellectuels entre comme ça j'ai
googlé le titre exact
c'était un épisode un épisode voile sur
ce thème de la masturbation
intellectuelle et j'avais mis une
masturbation dedans parce que je me
doutais que c'était pas une bonne idée
ouais j'avais mis au nanisme ou encore
des cartes et on en fait je veux garder
mais pour pendant longtemps c'est un peu
ça ce qui me servait de réserve de
scripts c'était en gros de prendre mes
cours et de les transformer en un court
marché qui tiendrait en tête 15e alors
au jour aujourd'hui c'est devenu sept
minutes on métier aujourd'hui tu es
vulgarisateur professionnel sur internet
sur youtube à partir de quel moment
à partir de quelle vidéo peut-être tu as
senti que il se passait quelque chose qu
on passer au niveau supérieur en nombre
d'abonnés que tout à coup tu l'avais un
nom dans ce milieu là parce qu'à un
point de bascule comme ça alors en
termes d'abonnés ce qui a vraiment qui
bascule et des trucs à la fin de la
première année c'était le bac en fait de
façon assez prévisible et que par sais
que j'ai fait une vidéo spéciale valent
pas un truc comme ça qu'un match
convient marché d'ailleurs la mieux
marché que toutes les vidéos spécial bac
que j'ai pu faire des années suivantes
alors que je pense que c'est clairement
la moins bonne mais c'est justement
parce que c'était la plus courte déjà y
aura en fait appel
h&m fait dix minutes puis georges et
donnent l'illusion que dix minutes on
peut savoir car une dissertation
mais du coup ça va marcher et ouais ça
ça m'a donné un vachement de visibilité
et sinon avant ça c'était si je commence
à avoir pas mal de d'interactions avec
votre vulgarisateur en fait très tôt
david loix c'est promis qu'ils makina
partagé qui martèle et je vais même pas
avoir 300 abonnés je pense que j'avais
sorti quatre vidéos peut-être y jetaient
sur l'innocence étonnante et voila c le
boss il faisait partie aussi de ceux
dont je me disais il a il a un style
comme ça très sobre l'idée qu'il faut
faire des montages et le travail ça
c'est marrant parce qu'en fin de compte
je pense que j'ai un montage 4 semble
acquis relativement peu desserré finale
plus que ce que j'imaginais faire départ
d'une des parties faisait bon je vais
faire en gros ce que je fais en cours
car oui la frêle faire assez vite je
supprime goût du du montage et j'aime
bien faire des trucs c'est un peu ce que
vous disent les valentins tout à l'heure
elle a commencé en poste en postant des
vidéos qui était de son propre aveu un
peu chiante parce que bon il faisait ce
qu'elle peser à l'école entre guillemets
et puis ensuite a commencé à injecter
plus d'humour et sa chaîne a pris un
tournant qu'elle n'avait pas prévu à la
base donc toi c'est ça s'est passé un
peu la même chose que tu as pris goût au
montage et tout à coup le surtout au
début c'est le côté très sympa de
commencer la chaîne youtube c'était
d'apprendre à faire du montage petit à
petit aujourd'hui encore je suis pas
très fort mais mais petit à petit on
maîtrise des truands on arrive à chaque
vidéo a ajouté un petit élément nouveau
et c'est super agréable dans longtemps à
l'apprentissage du montage était
vraiment ce qui me motivait a continué
peut pas parce qu'il est très pratique
au début parce qu'au début
un public énorme et donc forcément ça
peut être un peu long au début mais il
ya toute cette phase 4 ans à monter
table ronde est tout nouveau pour moi en
l'occurrence c'était à monter mes yeux
dit que pour d'autres chaînes ça peut
être des ressources que vous final cet
apprentissage c'est presque le principal
moteur plus que
le public conclut ce qui finalement un
bon moment c'était ça qui me motive et
grands clubs ok sûreté assuretat chaîne
tu parles beaucoup de parle beaucoup de
moral de philosophie morale
donc il ya eu pas mal de vidéo dans
laquelle je présentais des dilemmes
fameux dilemme du trolley et d'autres
évidemment
et là il se trouve que la situation
actuelle a fait que tu as pu donc réunir
le contexte et la théorie quoi la
pratique et la théorie donc tt2 dernière
vidéo traite de la situation actuelle et
notamment les essais cliniques que ta
dernière vidéo en date s'appelle les
essais cliniques sont ils immoraux ou
qu'est ce que tu peux nous en parler un
petit peu qu'est ce qui te donne qu'est
ce qui t'a donné l'idée de cette vidéo
et de quoi tu nous parles devant la
vidéo précédente je suis parle parce que
par rapport à l'idée que je faisais
beaucoup de philosophie morale que tout
à coup il ya l'actualité qui a car il
est qui qui rompt ses expériences de
pensée de philosophie morale super
actuelle c'est surtout pour la vidéo
précédente parce que j'avais fait au
départ une vidéo qui était bien la
première fois que j'avais avec le lait
de ses histoires volent actuellement
vaches qui ont bien marché c'était c'est
une vidéo qui marche le mieux sur la
chaîne et c'était en gros d'une série de
l'expérience de pensée autour du thème
en gros on a on a cinq machines pour
sauver six patients dont c'est ça l'idée
et savoirs acquis à qui on donne les
ressources médicales en taxant plus
limités et donc il ya eu plein de
variantes autour de ce dilemme là pour
rendre le truc le plus en plus difficile
en gros bout d'un moment il ya forcément
un moment où tu vas choisir de mettre
toutes les machines sur un seul des
patients et sacrifier les 50 et non
grasse et s était resté dans
l'expérience de pensée très classique et
vivent des expériences et quelque part
et puis là tout à coup il ya eu ce qu'on
voyait en italie où on avait les
témoignages de médecins qui expliquait
en eau
ce qu'on vit là c'est que on n'a pas
assez de ressources pour sauver tout le
monde va faire des choix de dire qui est
acquis on alloue les ressources à qui on
ne donne pas en sachant que sa peau ce
sera probablement la mort de ceux à qui
on n'a pas
des ressources et donc c'était vraiment
c'était quasiment une application
directe
oui de ce genre de dilemme là c'était
assez partait donc j'ai fait une vidéo
autour de ça en basant sur des
recommandations qui était formulée dans
le new england journal of medecine thiam
dans la référence académique et qui
disait assez clairement ce qu'il fallait
faire un genre de cas où effectivement
il faut allouer les ressources de façon
à maximiser donc de patience pour aller
kravitz à ce qui peut amener à faire des
choix extrêmement extrêmement douloureux
extrêmement compliqué et voilà en tout
cas j'ai voulu en parler même si c'est
délicat d'en parler qu'on n'est pas
médecin et que voilà on à mort ça de
loin mais efficace g j'imagine que ça
doit être ça doit être
gg j'hésite à dire que c'est comme une
opportunité mais j'imagine que le fait
de mettre en application des théories
qui sont censés rester théorique la
plupart du temps c'est quand même une
opportunité rare en matière de
philosophie on peut mettre à l'épreuve
en fait de la réalité nos idées et nos
réflexions sur ce sujet la cua et donc
toi en l'occurrence donc sur cette vidéo
vaut-il trier les patients
est ce que quelqu'un quels sont les
critères qui sont retenus donc est ce
que tu pourrais me l'expliquer
rapidement quels sont les critères qui
sont revenus pour savoir qui ont sauvé
qui on sauve pas du coup alors il
en tout cas dans l'arctique bon chemin
qui l'a qu'ils ont une référence
après la question se pose de savoir dans
quelle mesure les médecins suivent
effectivement segade line pas mais en
tout cas dans l'article c'est assez
clair que l'optique aller
conséquentialiste disons dire qu'on va
fixer comme objectif de d'avoir les
meilleurs conséquence possible en terme
de nombre d'années d'espérance de vie
sauvée ou en termes de nombre de vies
sauvées
ça peut avoir d un petit débat là dessus
mais en tout cas la proche globalement
elle est clairement orienté conséquence
on dit il fit des articles de
conséquents seront ainsi de maximiser et
ensuite toutes les décisions qu'on prend
un boiteux relatives à ça donc on
approche les conséquences et liste
effectivement si c'est intéressant parce
que c'est ce dont je parlais dans
vidéo qui dira c'est une approche très
importante on refuse du moral depuis je
suis moins dix huitième siècle
l'approchent conséquentialiste ou
utilitariste et elle a vraiment on a une
illustration du fait que c'est bien
cette accroche là qu'on retient dans des
moments de crise pareille c'est très
clair que la de tout l'article de guider
par cette intuition poser quand c'est
lui qui me dit bon abandonné même si
c'est pour prendre des décisions
compliquées on va les justifier par
rapport aux conséquences qu'elles
amènent donc en l'occurrence sauver un
maximum de vies même lorsque sam est là
à faire des choix compliqués du genre à
traiter des patients parce qu'ils sont
trop bas âge et parce que leur histoire
d'oublier et fm par rapport à
l'espérance de vie d'un autre passion
pour être apte et avec les mêmes
ressources herman la table et là aussi
c'est une leçon qu'on peut tirer des
vidéos que tu fais ta philosophie morale
c'est qu' il n'y a pas vraiment
d'instance supérieur qui peut nous dire
quel est le bon choix en fait il ya des
arguments des deux côtés on est il ya un
choix qui est fait mais personne ne peut
dire que c'est la bonne solution on oui
c'est la question médiatique c'est à
dire qu'il ya des questions éthiques
c'est en quelque sorte ce à quoi répond
le artix et à des questions éthiques
voilà qu'est ce qu'il faut faire mais la
question métallique ce serait de se
demander mais pourquoi est ce qu'il faut
faire ce qu'il faut faire pour qu est ce
qu il faudrait que ces guidelines été
mis quelque part de forcément on ne peut
pas y répondre
et forcément c'est des questions
extrêmement compliqué pourquoi est ce
qu'il faudrait être utilitariste
conséquentialiste il n'y a pas trace si
j'allais bac a pas de réponse parce
qu'en fait il ya il ya beaucoup de
choses qui sont écrits qui sont
disponibles sur ce sujet là mais en tout
cas c'est clairement une des questions
les plus épineuses qui ont fait la
philosophie morale
cette question mais tahiti de savoir
pourquoi est ce que on doit faire pour
moi car j'ai dû consacrer quelques
vidéos à des intrigues autour de ça mais
c'est très compliqué on peut aussi avoir
une aptitude pas du tout et tu joues pas
réaliste du tout c'est à dire en fait on
doit pas car ce qu'on doit faire on doit
pas y'a rien qui n'y a pas d'obligation
morale on sent ce marquage très strict
après les gens font ceci ou cela c'est
une façon assez simple de résoudre le
problème
pas forcément et puis qui laisse
forcément quand même ouverte la question
de savoir oui mais mon concrètement là
qu'est ce qu'on fait et pourquoi on fait
une question compliquée alors on est
question de l'eau dans le tchad alexia
qui nous dit que penses tu des
récurrences haute et dernière vidéo
est-ce quelque chose auquel tu ne
t'attendais pas la vidéo
c'était donc la vidéo que farid essais
cliniques donc ça c'est un autre
problème qui était donc tout ce que j'en
entendais passé autour de du professeur
marseillais le fameux et et pendant dix
jours et des jours je n'osais pas écrire
une vidéo baptisée nantes il y était
vraiment tiraillé entre le côté je veux
pas en parler parce que ça va être
horrible parce que j'ai déjà aidé par
des rats qui seront payés bien j'ai pu
tester l'idée à ce qui fait des vidéos
qui était rentrée c'était pas joyeuse
qui se passait dans les commentaires et
et en même temps voilà ça parlait
beaucoup de philosophie d'arguments
épistémologique complètement bidon alors
j'ai pas abordé le côté psychologique
mais génie quand même a un truc sur
l'aspect éthique parce qu'il me semblait
que le truc important c'était c'est être
souligné à quel point
on est de retour après un peu désolé de
cette situation
ça arrive à être que c'est les aléas du
direct encore une fois cette formule est
magique nous reste quelques miettes on
est toujours avec thibault alors moi de
mon côté
l'image de thibaut est figé vince à la
régie est ce que tu me confirme que
c'est normal toi moi ça chez moi tu es
figé thibault sache peu mais pour les
gens n'en faisant du figuier dans une
belle pause est solidement semaine un
bel arrêt sur image pour le coup oui
dont tu nous disais que les réactions à
thé dernière vidéo qui parle de
l'actualité on mettait de bonne saine
réaction en même temps que tu as un bon
public qui est à la hauteur de ton
contenait donc c'est pas étonnant
est-ce que tu as prévu de faire une
nouvelle vidéo sur la situation actuelle
est ce que tu as vu des choses qui
tombent qui tombent deux bennes remplies
justement de 2 des bleus
mais un petit peu certains certains
concepts philosophiques ou pas
spécialement alors à chaque fois j'ai au
départ j'ai prévu d'en faire aisément
puis en effet une pige en effet de ça
m'ennuie je dis pas cette fois ça
m'ennuie pas au sens à sa vie ennuyeuse
mais je trouve ça j'aimerais revenir à
des vidéos normal parce qu'il parle
pourrait faire ça va faire de ces vidéos
normal ça mais c'est moins stressant
c'est mais j'ai peut-être quand même y
revenir il y avait une petite idée de
deux vidéos qui tels que je trouve
amusant c'est parce qu'on parle beaucoup
des passeports d'immunité cette idée de
contesterait les gens ici sont humains
si le test sérologique revient positif
et bien voilà on se dit ils sont et
seront utilisés et il ya un truc c'est
amusant c'est que si le test sérologique
et pas ultra fiable en tout cas ultra
spécifique c'est jacky des textes qui
n'a jamais donné un faux positif
en fait c'est une très mauvaise idée
parce que la plupart des gens qui vont
qui vont passer le test et à avoir un
résultat positif qui leur permettra
d'avancer pour d'humilité en fait la
plupart ce sera des faux positifs parce
que parce que comme une application de
la formule de belges en fait et j'avais
fait une vidéo qui raconte presque
exactement ça ça c'est drôle vraiment
mais semée sur un cac abstrait vous
rendre malade imaginaire jeudi larry
downing street sa touche une personne
sur un million entre comme ça et dont il
est passionné de soi raisonnement pour
montrer que si on avait un test fiable à
80 à 95% dans celle-ci vous passer le
test c'est qu'il est qu'il est correct
vous avez moins de 10% de chance d'avoir
la jeune fille est envolé en sortant
d'une situation où c'est exactement ça
mais avec mise en situation réelle et
avec des cas des séquences possiblement
donc c'est évidemment une question de
proportions forcément même 1 % d'erreurs
sur les millions de personnes bah ça
représente énormément de cas quoi ces
associations un million de personnes que
tu testes en fait il y en a 10 ans 9 190
milles qui sont qui sont malades et
dix mille qui sont malades bon alors je
vais à détecter les 10000 qui sont
malades ok c'est bon et mais par contre
sur les 9 190 milles qui sont pas
malades pacifique qui est un peu de faux
positifs et ça va faire tout de suite
énormément en fait le seul cas qui va
être détectés positifs et qui enveloppe
ne le sont pas donc voilà je me disais
ça pouvait être une idée un peu
amusantes
je sais pas si tu es comme beaucoup je
pense que je pense que ce serait une
bonne idée même si du coup ça tomberait
peut-être un peu dans la redite parra
pour la vidéo club fait c'est exactement
ce jeu là mais alors pour terminer cette
émission on va parler de tes
recommandations culturel thibault donc
tu as un livre un jeu vidéo et une série
à nous conseiller
donc oui j'ai été divers oui le jeu
vidéo c'est à vue j'ai terminé hier il a
acheté au début du confinement
je suis un peu lente que je faisais jean
rapide par jour et ces peuples à l
innocence c'est un jeu français en fait
et c'est ça se passe pendant c'est un
peu de circonstance ils vont me dire que
ça fasse pendant l'épidémie de peste
walf 3 rapports pendant une épidémie de
peste en france au 14e siècle et c'est
un jeu c'est un espèce de survival
horror ac on voit beaucoup de morts
c'est extrêmement morbide et comment
comme ambiance
et en même temps là c'est pas
c'est assez touchant en fait c'est assez
émouvant parce que le personnage
principal les deux personnages
principaux en gros c'est une fille de
l'adolescente et puis son petit frère et
ils essayent de survivre au milieu de
tout ça passait un petit peu sa gu mais
petit à petit on devient on commence à
être un peu plus trop actif dans ce
concours commence à attaquer un peu les
des gens qui nient qu'ils nous
poursuivent à des dangers qui nous
guettent
mais pendant une bonne partie du jeu en
fait on est extrêmement on est
extrêmement vulnérables et donc c'est ça
rend le jeu d'ailleurs la progression
intéressante c'est qu'on passe vraiment
un moment où on extrêmement vulnérable
on doit essentiellement se cacher en
fait d éviter les de se faire tuer un
moment où devient plus dangereux pour
les autres s'y est donc ça avance a
mentionné dans l'agréable et ça c'est un
jeu vraiment bien les cris globalement
et des trois longueurs mais si tu as vu
des parallèles avec la situation
actuelle
pas du tout c'est pas vraiment le même
genre d'épidémie fille c'est un peu un
jeu fantastique je veux dire aussi
inséré une ambiance fantastique avec de
l'alchimie de trucs comme ça c'est pas
on ne fait pas très créatif et là le
même genre de trucs est ce un jeu assez
romanesque
si jamais j'avais bien s'il y avait
vraiment une qualité romanesque un peu
comme on trouve dans un laps de temps de
jeu en fait y'a pas sa servante une
histoire et l'histoire est intéressante
et nous avons tout pour ça donc pts
alors je rappelle que vous permettra à
toutes les suggestions dans les
descriptions de la vidéo de là puisque
jean les vidéos
ensuite je voulais vous parler dans le
livre oui ça à un recueil de nouvelles
de greg egan qui est sorti il ya
quelques mois peut-être quelques
semaines il s'agit bien de ces patchs ya
pas très longtemps
il est même qu'au courant alors c'est
vraiment mes auteurs de science-fiction
le feu
et oui là il faut le suivre sur twitter
il a très peu d'abonnés mais je suis sur
twitter il coûte que l'épreuve de maths
un peu improbable et notamment il avait
tout est là comme ça entre deux entre
deux trucs de mct improbable que il
sortait un nouveau livre et qu'il était
à vendre il est il est peint à vendre en
physique ce qui est vraiment juste en
ligne en 2 3 et 6 et 3 euros
l'essai de douze 12 nouvelles et voilà
enfin si tu aimes américain reprend le
dessus et c'est un anglais qui est qu'il
veut vraiment pas trop difficile à lire
et c'est alors j'ai pas encore fini
lis un peu dans le désordre la dernière
que je dis qu'il est la dernière du
roman du livre ces îles mais c'est très
amusantes ou en gros c'est des pnj de
jeux vidéo dans un imaginaire future
avancé où vous les pnj rue jeux vidéo
ont développé vraiment des expériences
consciente et une vraie conscience et
qui qui vivent dans la clandestinité
seriez de réussi à s'échapper de leur
jeu de base et essayent d'exploiter des
failles dans le temps du serveur de la
puissance de calcul dans les serveurs de
l'éditeur de jeux donc survivre
et puis il ya toute une ambiance autour
d'un dans le jeu vidéo c'est très
bizarre et devant un milliard d'années
dans les romans de grieg al ejelat
notamment une des idées que j'adore
c'est que ils essaient d'infiltrer un
jeu qui est une sorte de call of duty
mais à l'époque du cercle de vienne
c'est à dire les logiciens comme gödel
tard ce qui est c'est dans les années 30
et donc voilà c'est à moitié il ya une
résistance et on imagine que les et que
c'est se servent de logicien est entré
dans la résistance et commence à faire
des missions pour la voilà pour la
résistance et donc c'est un mélange de
call of duty et du cercle de vienne et
moi part ça c'est génial
greg egan pour ceux qui ne connaissent
pas donc c'est un auteur de
science-fiction qui s'est fait connaître
en france par les recueils radieux
océanique et axiomatique et la critique
mais et c3 hooker il font partie pour
moi en tout cas des meilleurs recueil de
nouvelles de science-fiction qui soit
parce que c'est une science fiction qui
est extrêmement intelligente et cérébral
est riche et complexe
et c'est vrai qu'il ya mis des parts
nouvelles est ce que dans ce recueil là
on est sur quelque chose de similaire
est ce qu'il va encore plus loin que
dans ses recueils tu le ferais comment
par rapport à dieu et à actionnariat
j'en ai pas encore trouvé une qui mais
je n'ai pas les mots pour ajourner lui
j'en ai lu 3 c'est la très bien que je
lis là je suis assez lent mais pour
l'instant je n'ai pas trouvé une qui me
talbot avait plutôt pas mal parti mais
j'attends de voir ce que veut dire la
barre est haut
quand je dis ça c'est que là bas elle
est super super hot c'est à dire
les rockets précédent il y avait il y
avait des chefs-d'oeuvre mais vraiment
hormis les meilleures nouvelles les
meilleures oeuvres de fiction que j'ai
dû moi c'est l'autre
c'est l'auteur du mind fucké du mind
blot baumard excellent en soit voilà
c'est ça s'est donc vu le mail de mein
blot que tu avais dans les deux
précédents forcément il va falloir qu'il
y ait sérieusement pour arriver à même
niveau et j'espère qu'il y en aura qui
seront qui seront de ce niveau là je lui
fais une relativement confiance ça
faisait longtemps que j'avais pas sortie
des nouvelles donc ça me fait d'autant
plus plaisir de lire tout ça est le
dernier endroit est une série web alors
je sais pas si tu l'as vu ça
m'arrangeait trembler les tableaux un
truc je vais chercher à le chercher une
série pour compléter le truc et je me
demandais qu'est ce que j'ai vu il n'y
avait rien qui me tenter et puis il ya
le tales from the loop qui est normal 10
de trucs que je regardais et en fait je
n'ai pas encore vu mais je sais je suis
quasi sûr ça va me plaire
voilà de quoi donc je veux je prends le
risque de conseiller sans l'avoir vu
alors en gros pour décrire le truc c'est
un mec s'appelle sinon et j'ai
totalement oublié le nom sinon stallone
hague
je ne sais pas comment ça te dit qu'il
n'ait pas creusé des démons des livres
c'est aides et c'était des livres d'art
fatigués des illustrations et le thème
de ces illustrations c'est en gros choc
c'est la norvège car un pays comme ça
nordique assez assez froid c'est avec
des grands espaces désertiques et dans
lequel il un serbe des éléments rétro
futuriste des trucs du genre des espèces
de robots géants mais en ruine un peu
vieux un peu bizarre un peu saugrenue il
y en a notamment qu' on dépose à ses 6
me est comme ça après de gaulle mid et
noval et c'était des livres qui étaient
essentiellement fait pour mais il est un
petit élément narratif peut-être dedans
pour relier les différents types soit
réellement fait c'était essentiellement
pour mettre en valeur ses illustrations
et en gros il a eu un énorme succès avec
ses beats je crois qu'il y avait une
idée à financer des partis juste sur
internet après la finance et des tirages
par kickstarter qui ont une super des
marchés et genre il s'était acheté les
droits pousser
brrr par toutes sortes de gens et
notamment donc là l'un de ses livres sa
peine tales of the loop est donc adapté
par prime et je passais celle de la
science fiction futuriste un peu un peu
ni déprimante me contemplatif comme ça
va être serré nous plaire je suis
désistement sûr que ça va me plaire j'ai
vu les visuels déjà et je le dis c'est
une telle somme euros parce qu'un
rapport avec une boucle temporelle ou
pas dans la loge on peut c'est déjà un
petit peu des jeux pas trop qu'on
apprend tout par une corde à gauche mais
je sais que c'est vous les looks c'est
lié à un accélérateur de particules qui
est dans le coin et qui tient une pizza
effectivement je pense qu'il est tout
temporel non mais l'enjeu n'est pas tant
que ça vive oui en tout cas ça a l'air
vraiment magnifique et une des
illustrations de simon tags sont
vraiment des lip regarder ça sur la
durée c'est magnifique c'est c'est
glaçant hostile et en montant à ces mots
je vais rebondir
beaucoup de ces bouteilles sont même
plus que ça m'a donné aussi envie de le
voir si bon de remercier d'abord été
avec nous pour cette émission qui n'a
pas été sans embûches
désolé pour cette page et technique je
rappelle que donc vous retrouver le
régler de cette section montée du coup
ce sont les petites roues d'ici d'ici
quelques heures sur la chaîne youtube
vous retrouvez aussi toutes les
références dans la description de la
vidéo on se retrouve nous vendredi à 17
heures avec de nouveaux invités
merci thibault merci valentine est avec
nous et je rappelle que cette émission
réalisée avec le soutien du cnc le cnc
qui met à disposition une plateforme qui
vous permet de retrouver toutes les
heures il existe en vod s'appelle vod
point cnc point fr donc si vous cherchez
un film en vod ou une série ou un
documentaire vous pourrez retrouver sur
quelle plateforme il est disponible sur
ce site voila
à très bientôt très bonne soirée à vous
à vendredi